hey you you look great yeah specifically
you with the Shiva moosh am I giving you
enough attention please do not cause
climate change
riding with grace it's ready with grace
cuz I really don't want to write this
whole thing by myself it's writing with
grace writing with me me my name is
grace over 25% of you in your
submissions this week decided that
loudmouth cause freak week because they
weren't getting enough attention which
hits a little close to home I'll be
honest please like and subscribe don't
ever leave and I think that you are
great I don't know what you're capable
of which brings us to this week's stats
everyone loves stat about 20% of your
submissions this week had Harry having a
bursting through the door moment this is
a really wonderful choice for me thank
you for doing that this week we've got
lotsa Lester's 10% of you wanted crush
to have a brother named Lester I don't
hate it
I'm just weirded out that a lot of you
have that very specific similar idea
about 30% of you mentioned some sort of
bobbington lock-picking which means that
you watch movie because that does not
work in the real world which brings me
to my next segment bobby pin life hacks
here are some things that bobby pins can
actually work for don't know how i get
that perfect sexy instagram pose don't
worry use a bobby pin ever wish that you
could make music but you don't have any
instruments i want to shake someone's
hand but hate germs
thank you for your business ever
struggle to eat popcorn with your bare
hands try a bobby pin
hmm worth it and that concludes our
bobby-pin life hacks let me know any
effects you have with bobby pins only I
just got so many bobby pins and I gotta
do something with them guys so help me
out and now on to our superlatives been
talking this week goes to in the corner
she decided that on day six everyone
says the exact opposite of what they
mean and she allows crush to have this
amazing monologue in which she professes
his opposite feelings for lace lace I
seriously hate you I have the strongest
disdain for you that I've ever felt for
another human being and it doesn't scare
me at all
I think you're completely disgusting in
so many ways not just your looks but
your personality and your mind as well I
hate you too I'm a porter just kidding
that's the price of the party this week
goes to raining apples let me give you a
hint at what they decided to include in
their chapter they decided to include
small parts of fear on their day six of
freak week that when people get afraid
they fart but just a little bit which is
maybe my favorite surprise surprise of
this whole series so far because like
that's a straight-up nonfiction right
there oh and her prom prize this week
goes to Matthew Frances Matthew Frances
decided that on day six of freak week
there is a tomato tornado everyone goes
around hurling insults at each other
like tomatoes at a vaudeville show or
that one day in Spain where they all
have the big tomato fight good job
Spain's Spain just loves frequent Mattel
brings us to our choice chapter for this
week by choice chapter this week is from
Nezumi Crabb
the Democratic chapter entitled syrupy
slopes on day six of freak week the
environment turns into candy but the
candy is reflective on your emotions
that you are experiencing I love in this
chapter that lace is talking about what
she loves about crush and she mentions
that she just loves his perfume which I
thought was a really fun choice to
decide that crush wears perfume good for
him
also the monologue comes from crash but
in a series of quick confessions as they
are rushing through the hallway to get
to the auditorium to confront loudmouth
who they learn is Lester crashes over
brother that none of us knew about but
is somehow the mastermind behind freak
we here's how it goes down crush is
actually responsible for helping build
the satellites and every time that loud
mouth messes with the satellites
something different happens on freak
week and it just coincidental that freak
week last for a week every year because
that's about how long it takes for crash
to get into the backlog system of the
satellites and reprogram them to stop
freak week that make any sense
read the chapter and the reason that
lace is the key is because all of the
answers to the pass codes that are
protecting the satellites have to do
with things about life her favorite band
lyric or a favorite chocolate and that's
why lace is so important what the
biggest thing that happens is that we
find out that loud mouth has banana but
banana wants to be there banana is
actually supporting loud mouth because
banana loves freak week and that's where
we are left off that everyone is now in
the auditorium it's loud mouth and
banana versus everyone else Jim is also
seeing loud mouth for the first time in
person and finding out who they actually
are after stored-up pseudo dating them
on a science forum oh also by the way
mr. Kevin is there with a water gun full
of honey if anyone was wondering like
myself where the hell mr. Kevin have
been
there here's what you need to do for
Chapter seven one this is the biggest
day of freak week this is our last day
make it good
- this is the confrontation this is the
quintessential fight scene and it has to
happen in an environmentally safe way ie
a rap battle
that's right this girl said rap battle I
use those words guys this is your last
chance to submit a chapter to freak week
I will be writing chapter 8 which is the
final final frontier of all of this but
chapter 7 in my opinion is maybe the
most important chapter it's the biggest
climax of the story also like set it up
so I can write a decent chapter a guys
and remember your deadline is this
Sunday May 15 to submit create a new
story on your Wattpad page and use the
hashtag writing with grace so we can
find your submission also if you want to
read freak week as it is up until now go
to Wattpad comm slash writing with to
check it all out and good luck oh yeah
you're just statistics that I forgot to
mention earlier last week freak week was
number one in general fiction on Wattpad
that's really difficult to do so
congratulations to you guys because you
are doing this best of luck to all of
you I'll see you on the internet here
all the time I don't know